i've done the seven day free trial of
the qurani app and it exceeded all my
expectations brothers and sisters you
can build a habit with the quran by
seven day free trial bonuses no credit
card details required at all and you
decide for yourself is it overrated or
is it underrated
assalamu alaikum welcome to better care
brothers and sisters and dear friends
imagine you're on instagram and you just
randomly come across this video
now what would your first impression be
so just let's have a good look at this
yeah okay so this sister may allah bless
her you see her and once you see her
what is the first thing that comes to
your mind now i'll be very frank and
very honest when i see this video
or if i wasn't not to play it there's a
lot of things that will come to my mind
for example i would think and i'm just
have to be honest here i would have
think that it's just a non-muslim girl
um she might be someone who does i don't
know fitness
she might be someone that's talking
about um you know cryptocurrency maybe i
don't know yeah um
she might be someone that goes clubbing
on the weekend uh she might be someone
that's just into having fun in life uh
yolo you live you only live once um so
we generalize a lot and a lot of people
don't do this with us muslims as well
now
let's see what this video was actually
about
because this shows is a massive massive
lesson
let's watch that video and let's come
back and learn some key lessons
inshaallah so i think the number one
most important thing is you put the
intention out there so like for me i
have the intention i will not go to bed
rest or relax
unless i do my fight for the day because
i really really don't think i deserve to
lay my head down and go to sleep unless
i've given the creator the time that he
is deserved and owed to be honest so set
your intention because if you don't have
that intention you're never gonna do it
make your plans around prayer so like i
am comment and you have to know the
prayer times to do that so download an
advan app get familiar with the prayer
times and when you go to make plans for
example like if you're going to hang out
with your friends wait until esha goes
off pray your each other you go have fun
for the rest of the night
you don't have to worry about it and i
think like another really important tip
is just get off your phone put your
phone down stop distracting yourself
because these distractions are gonna do
us in okay
so if you haven't prayed yet get off
your phone and go do your salad so guys
as you saw for yourself like when i even
showed that to my wife and i said
looking at this video like you know this
girl
what comes to your mind she was like you
know maybe someone that likes to have
fun outgoing party someone that's a
party girl etc and i was like wow like
you know we generalized and i did this
before in speaker's corner as well sadly
you know it's not something that we want
to do but it's just
you know maybe we're just
conditioned or whatever it may be okay i
saw a a um sister for example cause i
was gonna double leaflet south et cetera
so i saw a sister blonde hair etc
standing there and i thought let me give
it to her and then brother came and said
oh she's a muslim and i was like oh my
gosh
like the thing is yeah obviously
i'm not to blame because i'm giving down
material together and i'm looking at
like to me anyone that has a beard or
looks like a little muslim but there's
you can't really say there's a specific
person that looks like a muslim of
course you have the symbols etc but
isn't it amazing that's so
beautiful
and heartwarming that
muslims all over the world especially in
the west a lot of women are flocking to
islam yeah a lot of women are flocking
to islam alhamdulillah because islam
gives the rights of a woman in the right
way and honors her so this sister when
she was speaking and she was talking
about
i do my five a day and i'm thinking five
a day i'm thinking okay you know
apple oranges make sure she has a five a
day
and then
when i saw it and she was talking about
prayer
i was like damn like like subhanallah
like first i was so happy secondly it
made me realize you know what ali don't
ever think or judge people and think you
know what this person is not one lie you
guys do not know if we saw that sister
walking down the road there's some
brothers they'll be looking at thinking
oh she's probably like this or like i
should play with one of these girls you
know nothing about it and that's why
it's so important to not to have
negative assumptions allah says in the
quran that even negative assumptions can
be a sin we should assume the best who
would have thought that this is a sister
who praised her salah five times a day
and she's given a reminder that we
should all pray our salah who would have
thought that
who would have thought that none of us
do not ever judge a sister who wears
hijab or doesn't wear the hijab you do
not know the effect the same with the
brother a brother who might be dressed
to play in a certain way has the earring
whatever it may be we should never judge
and this is what this exactly taught me
and it was such a beautiful thing to see
that muslims come from in different
shapes and different colors
alhamdulillah and what really stood out
to me is that her dedication to a salah
we have don't forget guys we do have
people individuals who may observe the
hijab within the kaaba don't praise
allah so it's very important for us and
i'm not belittling that oh we should not
wear the hijab no we should do that also
as well and we ask allah to make easy on
this river sister inshallah when they
should wear the hijab as well but salah
is so key in her life that she has
acknowledged it brothers and sisters
this is what i wanted to share with you
guys i found it beautiful how did you
find it and what was your first
impressions uh maybe maybe maybe not
it's best not to share maybe first
impressions but i hope you learned a
lesson uh as much as i did
and may allah bless her please i'm gonna
send this video to her as well may allah
keep you firm sister my dear sister may
allah bless you with the best in this
life and hereafter and keep you uh going
inshaallah with these amazing reminders
and keep firm to your salah you're gonna
have your ups and downs
i'm gonna go till next time brothers and
sisters inshaallah let's not judge
anybody based on how they look however
however they look um and whatever the
appearance they meet they may be because
they might be more close to allah than
you and me
actually rhymed till next time